[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
if you'd like to help support my channel
and get early access to every video
consider becoming a patron at
patreon.com second thought
i know we're all tired of hearing about
coronavirus and would rather just put
the last year behind us
but the recent pandemic has now morphed
into something entirely different
in the last few months the narrative
around covet 19 has shifted from how to
stop it
to where it came from we're beginning to
hear a lot of mainstream news figures
including many who ridiculed the
previous administration adopt a very
similar language as was used by trump
and his more rabid fans
in this episode we're going to talk
about the resurgence of the lab leak
hypothesis
what it means and discuss the state of
biological warfare capabilities around
the world
fairly early in the pandemic a popular
talking point on the political right was
that the coronavirus had originated in a
chinese laboratory
trump presented this hypothesis in his
typical crass casually racist manner
and his fans ate it up the corporate
media and democratic politicians widely
criticized this idea as being unfounded
and without evidence
and the prevailing narrative was that
the virus originated from animal to
human transmission
likely in a marketplace in wuhan now a
year later
the biden administration has officially
launched an inquiry into the lab leak
hypothesis
and what had long been dismissed as a q
anon conspiracy theory suddenly became a
mainstream liberal talking point
news networks like cnn and msnbc are
conducting daily panel discussions on
the history of chinese secrecy and
biological research
while it has been funny to watch
conservatives denounce their once dearly
held hypothesis because liberals have
adopted it the shift in political and
media rhetoric should be telling
let's start with a few facts coronavirus
most likely originated in wuhan china
there is a biological laboratory in
wuhan which is located very near the
markets which were the supposed origin
of the disease
from wuhan it spread all over the world
with individual nations handling the
crisis in their own way
some much more effectively than others
china was not terribly prompt with
announcing the spread of the infection
which was irresponsible though
understandable if they thought they
could contain it
over the past year more than 3.7 million
people have died from the virus
the u.s leading the way with 612 000
deaths
nearly twice the number of the second
worst affected country india the u.s
coveted response was arguably the worst
in the world
especially given the vast resources at
our disposal and
hundreds of thousands of deaths could
have been prevented if our government
had acted promptly and effectively to
contain the spread of the virus
so why have both conservatives and now
liberals latched onto the lab leak
hypothesis
it has very little to do with finding
the truth in fact
it has everything to do with obscuring
it managing it
and that should be obvious with how
quickly those in power have shifted
their narrative when it suddenly became
convenient for them
over the last 15 months we've been fed
bits of information
only when it was beneficial to american
leadership and commercial interests and
not a moment before
first there was supposed consensus that
the virus came from infected bats
that there was no chance it came from a
lab that the u.s had no advanced
knowledge of what was coming
one president leaves another takes power
and suddenly the narrative completely
flips
now there's a consensus that a lab leak
is probable and that the chinese tried
to cover it up
where's the truth why are elected
officials and the corporate media so
hell bent on managing the flow of
information to the american people
as usual it has to do with power the u.s
is actively gearing up for war with
china and they need to manufacture our
consent
this is so obvious that no one should be
surprised when it becomes official
we're following the exact same playbook
as in the lead-up to the iraq war
24 7 media coverage serious words from
politicians about democracy and freedom
the whole nine yards but what makes this
instance different
is that the u.s is implicated in the
shady activity they're trying to pin on
china
now before we go any further we need to
understand something called
gain of function research in biological
laboratories
scientists sometimes engage in a
particular area of research that
involves altering an organism or disease
in a way that changes its process of
development
transmissibility or types of carrier
changes may be too soft a word
as gain of function research often aims
to increase a pathogen's threat level
you may be thinking okay that's terrible
why would anyone do that
but there is actually some value in this
type of study for example
if scientists managed to alter a
pathogen in such a way that allowed it
to infect an animal that previously
couldn't transmit the disease
it could give them valuable insights
into what specific parts of the pathogen
cause it to accept certain hosts
which is an important step in developing
antiviral medicines which block that
function
of course this also comes with the risk
of creating deadlier
mutant strains of disease that are
harder to cure gain of function research
is highly controversial
and with good reason theoretically it
could give us a head start on tackling
future pandemics
but on the other hand it could very
easily lead to accidental infection and
spread of mutant diseases
this some independent researchers are
beginning to suspect
is what happened with covid19 scientists
in bio labs around the world
engage in this kind of research and it's
not uncommon for there to be accidents
for example in the u.s the frequency of
lab incidents increased from 16 in 2004
to 269 in 2010
this predictably stems from a massive
expansion in u.s bio labs both at home
and stationed in other countries
the number of bio labs in the u.s alone
increased from 400 in 2004
to 1500 in 2014. there have been
suggestions that chinese scientists were
infected with coronavirus as early as
late 2019
well before the pandemic became global
news these allegations have been denied
but what does this have to do with the
u.s investigation
well according to some investigative
journalists china was cooperating with
united states and world health
organization officials on gain of
function research related to the
coronavirus
this was a fairly new development as
gain of function research had been
paused during the obama administration
but was later restarted under trump this
is a big deal
not only because it lends credence to
the lab league theory
but because it implicates top world
health organization scientists as well
as high profile american medical
professionals like dr anthony fauci
if this is actually the case if the us
and china were working together on gain
of function research on the coronavirus
if the u.s was funding it as the
reporting claims then it makes perfect
sense that the corporate media and both
administrations have worked so
diligently to control the narrative
they need to keep up the pressure on
china to manufacture consent for war
but they don't want the us to be
implicated in the crisis
it's damage control what's particularly
suspicious is that the world health
organization has appointed peter dashak
the president of the eco-health alliance
as the primary investigator into the lab
leak hypothesis
why is this suspicious because eco
health was reportedly the source of the
u.s funding for china's gain of function
research
that's like having a police station
investigate itself for police brutality
they're going to say it didn't happen
this is likely the us's way of preparing
to denounce china for criminal
negligence
while distancing themselves from the
blame it's no wonder china isn't being
cooperative with the us if the
investigation really is a sham
to draw a fairly recent parallel this
saga is like the muller report all over
again
highly publicized very dramatic
involving high profile investigations
and will probably yield an inconclusive
verdict in the hopes that the public
will just kind of accept it and move on
as a side note some of these details are
also being loudly proclaimed by some of
the most detestable right-wing figures
in america
but they're doing it simply to own the
libs any real evaluation of the
situation
must come with a material analysis of
power and how it is wielded in the
united states
as far as outcomes go if i had to guess
my money would be on any eventual report
being inconclusive and the u.s
continuing to ramp up its anti-china
rhetoric as a prelude to war
i'm sure we'll find out soon enough now
while the covid lab leak hypothesis is
the most current example of at least the
possibility of deadly viruses escaping
containment
it's only symptomatic of a larger
problem and that's the proliferation of
global biological weapons capabilities
as i mentioned earlier since the turn of
the century the us has built hundreds of
new biological laboratories
including more than 225 foreign
countries
and that's just the ones we know about
now biological weapons are completely
prohibited by a 1975 treaty called the
biological and toxin weapons convention
or btwc to which 183 countries are party
including all the major world powers as
of may 2021
there are 10 nations who have neither
signed nor acceded to the treaty
this short list includes america's
favorite ally israel
which does not bode well for
palestinians the btwc is regarded as
perhaps the most important arms treaty
of the 21st century
but it has two serious problems first
formal verification of compliance is not
part of the treaty
meaning the whole thing is basically on
the honor system as long as a nation
says they're not researching or
producing biological weapons
they're good second the treaty does not
prohibit defensive biological research
that is ways in which a nation can
combat biological warfare
if there's one thing we know about the
united states it's that everything we do
is classified as defense all our
invasions coups and wars are always cast
as defensive when they're clearly not i
suspect our defensive biological program
is no different
these two failures of the treaty combine
to make one very big problem
if nations are allowed to build and
maintain hundreds of biological research
facilities
and there's no one to confirm that they
are indeed defensive
how do you think the deeply distrustful
world leaders will see foreign labs
they'll see them as a threat they'll
assume their enemies are concocting
deadly biological weapons
and they'll feel pressured to do the
same it's a similar problem to nuclear
proliferation
if that country over there has nukes i'd
better have some too
except it's worse because unarmed nukes
can't silently infect people and escape
the military base
pathogens and diseases can the history
of biological weapons is secretive and
terrifying
back in the 60s the world's major powers
had reportedly
developed enough bio weapons to kill
every single person on earth
frankly we got very lucky one of the
more well-known u.s bio-warfare labs is
the top-secret dugway proving ground
established in 1942 to test biological
and chemical
weapons and located on over 800 000
acres of utah desert
roughly the size of rhode island much of
dugway's history and activity remains a
closely guarded secret
but there are some incidents that have
become public knowledge
one mistake that made headlines involved
a nerve agent known as vx
and roughly 6 000 sheep in march of 1968
a military plane blasted the nerve agent
into the air during a test
and the wind carried it some 30 miles to
nearby and aptly named
skull valley shortly after 6249 sheep
were found dead or dying
though the army has never admitted fault
they compensated the rancher who owned
the sheep and an investigation confirmed
that the animals had indeed been
poisoned by vx
this wasn't the only mishap involving
dugway in 2015
it came to light that dugway officials
had accidentally shipped live anthrax to
states across the country
shortly after it became apparent that
the problem was not new
and it sparked an investigation dugway's
history is riddled with questionable
projects
including testing bombs full of fleas
which they would presumably infect with
diseases and drop on target populations
or mosquitoes infected with inert
diseases which they tested on human
subjects
and various biological and chemical
weapons originally intended to be
deployed during the korean war
of course the u.s denies that these
weapons were ever used in combat
if we know about the weaponized fleas
and mosquitoes
i shudder to think of all the projects
we don't know about as dugway is still a
top secret facility
despite their recent pr attempts such as
hosting a trail race on their testing
grounds
i would definitely bring some bug spray
to that race another such facility is
fort dietrich in maryland
located on a much more modest 1200 acres
of land
fort dietrich is no less secretive and
dangerous than dugway
during world war ii personnel at the
installation produced
5 000 anthrax bombs for the military
though they were supposedly never used
between 1945 and 1955 as part of
operation paper clip
us leadership secretly recruited nazi
scientists to work on u.s military
programs
including chemical and biological
warfare many ended up at fort dietrich
including several who had actively
participated in heinous medical
experiments on concentration camp
inmates
like dugway the personnel at fort
dietrich also studied weaponized insects
including ticks fleas ants lice and
especially mosquitoes which they
infected with yellow fever
one author and expert on the subject
wrote in 2009
that it's highly likely that the us did
employ infected insect weapons during
the korean war to spread disease
as in the fall of 1950 the u.s joint
chiefs of staff had approved their use
quote
at the earliest practicable time during
the 1950s
the installation conducted countless
experiments involving biological agents
on human subjects
who according to the official record
were all volunteers
today like all the us's bio labs fort
dietrich supposedly conducts only
defensive programs
and has stopped production of any
biological or chemical weapons
hopefully that's actually the case
though i think it's wise to be skeptical
and even if the u.s and all the other
nations party to the treaty have
remained honest since the 1970s
the threat of accidental leaks and
exposure remains
case in point activity at fort dietrich
was temporarily suspended in 2019
for numerous breaches in protocol and
violations of federal procedure
in the cdc's report which contains
extensive redacted sections for supposed
national security reasons
they cite six departures from the
federal regulations for handling select
agents and toxins
as well as failure to implement
biosafety and containment procedures
bio labs especially those designated
bsl4
or biosecurity level 4 routinely house
incredibly dangerous pathogens
including some that have no known cure
and have the potential to be far
deadlier than kovit
with so many facilities and so much
secrecy
leaks are only becoming more likely and
an unwillingness of the involved nations
to announce their mistakes will make for
disastrous future pandemics
this governmental malpractice is
something that everyone regardless of
political beliefs should be against
blindly following your preferred
american political tribe is foolish
as we've seen clear evidence of
republican and democratic talking points
switching when it becomes convenient for
those in power
and the corporate media dutifully
promotes their propaganda
this topic is one of those things that
sounds conspiratorial when you really
get into it
but a little bit of historical reading
will show you that reality is often far
more bizarre than any conspiracy theory
the things that the world's governments
get up to and the propaganda campaigns
they produce
are insidious sophisticated and constant
i know this may seem bleak and i know
some people think my videos are too
depressing
but it's important to be aware of these
things it's not hopeless
there's always something normal people
can do to affect positive change
but it has to start with concrete
analysis who are the involved players
who stands to benefit from a certain
narrative the most critical thing
any of us can do is to determine the
fundamental aspects of any given problem
to understand its inherent
contradictions only then can we act in a
way that is informed and that drives us
towards positive change
if this most recent pandemic did
originate in a biological laboratory
i feel very confident in saying it was
not intentional
there's no need to stoke fears about
outright biological warfare
working with pathogens is very risky and
it might be worth having a serious
international conversation about the
benefits and the risks of such programs
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is made
possible by my patrons on patreon
this type of video while very important
is something that sponsors won't touch
in order to pay the bills and keep this
channel running i rely on adsense
revenue
sponsors and donations from generous
viewers by producing explicitly
anti-capitalist content
i lose out on both sponsors and adsense
if you enjoy the kind of videos i'm
producing and you're able to chip in
even a dollar a month
i would greatly appreciate the support
you can find my patreon page
join our growing discord server and get
early access to every episode at
patreon.com
second thought if you enjoyed this video
consider dropping a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you